oh hi that's wasn't expecting to see you
all undulating up here ah hi I just put
my jacket on the bed when I first came
to the party but I didn't realize that
the party made its way up here but I'll
get that now I will if you Carol I don't
know if you're in there somewhere but
wherever you are thank you for the
invitation I really enjoy myself I fee
at work tomorrow okay hey sir I think I
see my jacket I think I think your arm
is in the sleeve actually I'll grab
that's not my jacket and that's not your
arm it's not your arm why people are
crazy why people are crazy just lookin
for a jacket sir okay yeah very nice
moustache I've never seen one above the
nose that's interesting that's not your
nose okay sorry to disturb you sir just
lookin for a jacket that's the ordinary
man lookin for a jacket you want to say
something to me sir hmm no thank you
very much sir it tasted a little bit
like salty but but that's okay it's
tweed the jacket I'm talking about and
it's got leather patches on it just oh
maybe this is it thank you found it and
nope that's not it but congratulations
ma'am you are doing great with what God
gave you no don't look at me in the eyes
ma'am I don't want you to steal my soul
hi ladies nice to meet you and third yes
I do see you too okay oh no I'm okay I
really am I'm already seeing a group of
people and we're taking it slowly and we
are taking it slowly it's a church maybe
some of y'all would be interested in
looking into that not mine but one
somewhere if that's okay thank you ma'am
for there it is I found it found the
jacket it's right here I'm gonna pull it
and I believe it might be lodged
somewhere within ya I'm just guessing
because that is just a little bit of
resistance all right there we go you
know what that is going to be your keep
it thank you cover yourself up Carol if
you're in there I'll see you at the
office tomorrow just bring the bowl you
can finish the eggs
my god why people creep
you